they will go for anyone who stands up
hey how about elon musk check this
headline from the daily wire federal
government launches systemic racism
probe into tesla we got a little info on
that
california's department of fair
employment and housing said that it is
that it has received hundreds of
complaints from african-american workers
who claim they had been segregated to
the lowest levels of the workforce at
the company and lacked representation in
the ranks of executives senior officials
and managers tesla's most recent filings
with the sec indicated that the eeoc had
issued a finding that closely parallels
allegations from the state of california
yet tesla had formally called the dfeh
investigation misguided and an attempt
to generate publicity noting that every
one of the more than 50 uh
discrimination accusations faced by
tesla over the past five years has been
debunked by the de
the dfeh now the reason i bring this up
is obviously elon musk has become wildly
outspoken related to politics he tried
to buy twitter and at the very least has
exposed twitter to be
completely fraudulent he has gone on the
record saying he would support ron
desantis he voted for myra myra flores
in uh in texas
uh first time he says he ever voted for
a republican so then what happens next
thing you know
the sec is looking into his company
about systemic racism and by the way
i don't know the full racial breakdown
of every tesla employee i don't know it
but if you just happen to hire people
based on
their skills
their color will be irrelevant
so if you would like to work at a
company where they hire not the people
who are best skilled but based on their
sexuality or gender or color skin you're
not going to get the best product this
is simply true but that's a separate
issue the issue here is the gov this is
what these people do they weaponize the
government right this is the irs obama's
irs going after all the tea party groups
they use the levers of government to
destroy their opposition and why would
you do that because you have to distract
from the larger issues of course that
they've caused sort of like the
recession or as they call it the
non-recession here's black lesbian
corrine jean-pierre saying she's not
even going to tell you what recession
means
and what is exactly the white house's
definition of a recession again we don't
we don't def i'm not going to define it
from here i'm just going to leave it to
the nber as as we have stated how they
define uh recent recessions
i'm just saying that we're just not
going to define it we use the indicators
that the nber
the national national bureau of economic
research has used okay
she's not going to define it but whether
she defines it or not there is a
definition of recession that has been
the commonly used definition of
recession for a hundred years or
something like that and it's basically
two quarters in a row where things are
not going up that's pretty much back to
back two of those recession that's
pretty much how it works uh here's more
from corinne jean-pierre
next week's a very big week for the
economy so i read the cea blog is the
white house trying to change the common
definition of a recession because next
thursday the gdp numbers coming out are
going to show that we've been in
recession so let me say this you know
the strength of our labor market along
with the other economic
factors is what what we generally see in
a recession or even a pre a pre what
is not what we generally see in a
recession or even a pre-recession
because we're seeing the strength of the
economy and the labor market so that's
really important uh to note that
it's just nothingness it's just endless
nothingness that's that was the whole
point of that clip like they will
literally define redefine words right in
front of you this is what they do but
you can't be surprised by this if
someone says the two plus two is five
you might start thinking geez i'm not
sure that i want to trust this person
when it comes to defining other words